When you think about innovation
and technology,
you're most likely thinking
about the latest app on your smartphone,
or maybe you think
about rockets going into space.
But what about some of the world's
biggest challenges,
like global hunger or climate change?
They can seem overwhelming or, you know,
maybe you just think there
should be a nonprofit organization
that takes care of that.
But why is it that we think
so traditionally
about some of the world's
biggest challenges?
I believe innovation and technology
can help tackle some
of the world's biggest challenges.
The barrier is our own thinking.
And there's something about this
where big global challenges
are no different than big
global business challenges.
So let's change that.
Let's talk about one
of those topics, global hunger.
Hunger may seem
like a remote problem for you,
but the effects of it are pretty drastic.
Hunger means you do not have
enough calories on a daily basis
to live a healthy life.
And there is up to 811 million people
on the planet who are hungry.
So what can we do about it?
I think innovation
and technology is the answer.
A couple of years ago,
a friend and I realized
that United Nations World Food Programme
can feed a child for a full day
for only 80 cents.
We were shocked.
We thought, if more people
knew about this,
if we made it easy,
imagine you were having dinner
with your friends
and you're enjoying yourselves,
wouldn't you want to share
your meal with a child in need?
And that's exactly why we founded
an app called Share the Meal.
It's so simple.
With one tap on your smartphone,
you can share your meal with
a child in need for only 80 cents.
And I'm excited to tell you it's working.
Over 130 million meals
have been shared so far
by six million app users across the globe.
And Share the Meal was even
an app of the year in 2020
by both Apple and Google.
(Applause)
When we started Share the Meal,
we had to push really hard
to make it a reality.
There just weren't so many
support mechanisms out there
to support social entrepreneurs,
when you compare it, for instance,
with the number of start-up accelerators
for for-profit ventures.
Coming from that inspiration,
I got the opportunity to start
the World Food Programme’s
Innovation Accelerator,
exactly with the goal of replicating
what Silicon Valley does well,
but for global social impact.
It's a start-up accelerator
that supports start-ups
and nonprofit innovations globally
and helps them scale
to disrupt global hunger.
So let's look at two of those examples.
The first one is about blockchain.
Now, when you think about blockchain,
you may think about Bitcoin
or cryptocurrencies,
but that's not how we think of it.
We use blockchain technology
so that refugees can go into stores
and purchase food.
It's an innovation called Building Blocks.
And why blockchain?
Blockchain helps
because it's not my blockchain
or your blockchain,
it's the neutral blockchain network.
And that way it makes collaboration
among aid organizations much easier.
And how does it work?
Every month,
aid organizations transfer money
to individual blockchain accounts,
and then that individual
can go into a store,
shop for the groceries
and at the checkout
they pay with the iris scan
or with another authentication method.
That innovation had first
been submitted to us
by a World Food Programme finance officer
who participated
in our innovation boot camp.
He then developed
a prototype and tested it
only two months after starting,
in Pakistan with about 100 people,
and the next pilot was already
with 10,000 refugees in Jordan.
And that was so successful,
that that solution scaled
to over 100,000 people
within seven months.
And right now, Building Blocks
is reaching about one million people,
transferring over 300 million
dollars of cash
to people in urgent need of food.
(Applause)
And here's another example.
Did you know that corn flakes
and a lot of other cereals
have added vitamins and minerals?
That's called food fortification,
when you add critical nutrients
to staple foods we eat every day.
That's particularly important when people
do not have access to a healthy diet
or maybe they cannot afford it.
This is where social business
called Sanku comes in.
Sanku has developed
an internet-enabled machine
that fortifies maize flour
at small mills in Africa.
Now they have a market-based model
that helps provide fortified,
nutritious flour to their clients
of the small mills at no additional cost.
Right now it's reaching
up to three million people
and scaling further.
So, does it work?
Can accelerated innovation
and technology help us tackle
some of the world's biggest challenges?
When we first started the World Food
Programme Innovation Accelerator,
it seemed like a crazy idea
that innovation and technology
can help us make a meaningful impact
on global hunger.
But since starting in 2015,
we've consistently doubled the number
of people reached every year
through the innovations
that we've supported.
In 2021, we've positively impacted
the lives of 8.6 million people already.
And now we even run accelerator programs
for other global problems
like primary health care,
vaccine delivery or gender equality.
Imagine what the impact could be
if you take action today as an individual,
as a company, or maybe
as a start-up founder.
Innovation and technology can enable
so much good in the world,
and together we can solve
the world's biggest challenges.
Thank you.
(Applause)